not great news once again for Donald
Trump and this issue of having
undocumented workers involved with his
various organizations remember this
story about Trump's own wife Melania
Trump who it appears based on the story
she told of being modeling in the US but
having to leave to Slovenia reapply for
a visa and come back etc the way she
described her visa indicates she had a
visa that did not authorize her to work
in the United States every indication
that Melania Trump was working in the
United States illegally of course now
the wife of the candidate who is going
to fix the entire illegal immigration
problem we've now heard from Rachel
Blais who's a former Trump model
management model she was on CNN
yesterday morning and she told a very
similar story about her involvement in
modeling and her lack of authorization
no work visa for quite a bit of time
that she was doing work let's take a
look at rachel blazes own words here
can't do it so rachel that brings us to
you you worked with the Trump Model
Management for three years
what was your experience in terms of how
you got into the country and whether or
not you had the right visa I definitely
didn't have the visa I got in in April
2004 and I only got the visa in
September 2004 and between April and
August 2004 I spent most of my time in
New York and work that did a lot of jobs
to which they deducted taxes and but I
didn't have a visa until September I
didn't actually start the visa process
until August and so you say that it's
sort of normal in the industry and that
models know not to ask you many
questions but was there something
different about the Trump Model
Management Agency when they they skirted
the rules even more so than other places
that you worked yes I mean I work with a
different agency when I left Trump and
they got me my visa straight away some
girls get it quite quickly but it's
quite a spread out
way of working for agencies to not have
girls coming in with a work visa but for
example that summer in New York we were
about seven foreign models in that
apartment at least during that so
there's a number of stories here number
one is the fact that this is exactly the
same type of problem that is alleged
involving Melania Trump so it's not as
though we're hearing completely
different stories about the people
involved with Trump organizations and
modeling and visas etc etc this is
basically the same story mother jones
profiled for former Trump management
models and one of them was Rachel blaze
and a couple of the others who go by the
names Ana and Kate but these are
pseudonyms and that they spoke on the
condition of anonymity said they never
obtained their visas while working in
the United States and that actually they
were encouraged by Trump's agency to
deceive customs officials about why they
were visiting the United States that in
and of itself if true would be
completely criminal this should be a
campaign ender but it continues and it
is absolutely stunning that Donald Trump
has had numerous issues now we now know
about multiple models with the exact
same story working illegally in the
United States we know about the 200
undocumented Polish workers who were
involved in the demolition for a Donald
Trump real estate project this is a real
real issue and it's yet one of the other
ways Rachel in which what Trump's policy
is seems to directly contradict what it
is he has done in his life right so he's
kind of concocted this platform that
essentially contradicts all of his
business practices and it makes me think
okay are you going to start a war on all
of your ties in suits a trade war
because your ties and suits were made in
in Mexico are you I just it's the exact
same thing where he's the guy who's
going to bring back the production that
has been outsourced to Mexico and to
China wherever let's put aside for a
second that a lot of those jobs no
longer exist he's the guy who sent some
of those jobs to Mexico and China on
issue after issue Jason
it seems as though Donald Trump is just
saying what he thinks he should say to
get elected even though it directly
contradicts everything he's actually
done in life he's saying I will do as I
am saying today I will do not as I have
done for the last thirty years of my
business career I think Trump likes his
women like his business is originating
out of the country yeah I I think I
think you're exactly right there and
then of course we know about Trump
University that that seems to have been
a complete scam and there's one other
thing I want to touch on here towards
the end of that interview Rachel blaze
referenced there were seven or eight of
us or something
living in this New York apartment even
the way this is like a common way that
we models are brought to the US and
really not treated well which is in
addition to the fact that they are
brought here and told to lie to customs
and work illegally they are given these
apartments where they do pay rent seven
eight nine ten crammed into a
one-bedroom New York apartment
completely common story no work visas
and of course the management agency then
keeps a cut of the modeling income that
they get from the projects that Trump or
whoever it is that's managing their
modeling careers get this is also a scam
that it appears the Trump model
management was involved and which is of
course not unique to Trump this is a
common modeling scam that exists but
even that it seems the as as yet another
element of Trump's very shady business
practices doesn't it
right well he was just trying to bring
in as much revenue as possible so if
that's going to kind of subject these
models to completely in habitable
conditions he's going to do it yeah and
and it seems as though this is the trend
with Donald Trump every single
credential that he claims to have is not
that we've uncovered that just sitting
in index funds he would have a higher
net worth than he has now from all of
the great business deals that he's done
well by doing nothing and sitting around
he would have more money would he have
created as many jobs well depends on how
many jobs you believe the guy created I
think that that's absolutely part of it
very very disturbing and again if the
story's drastically conflicted I would
be way more skeptical but
when Rachel blaze jason tells us the
exact same story that has been seemingly
uncovered about Melania Trump and that
three other former models have
corroborated of course innocent until
proven guilty but as reasonable people
who are evaluating the allegations we
don't really have any mitigating
evidence do we yes listen to an
interesting news story on NPR on the way
in and they were talking about basically
how people predict in the base of
elections how people predict sports
games and if you look at the details
they're like one detail the people you
know look at these very single details
for a single game you're never gonna be
really right but if you look at let's
say a track record that someone has and
the things they build up over time
that's what you really have to look at
here he's building a track record give
I've always saying one thing and doing
another his words do not match his
actions no doubt about it and the the
saddest part is that because he's run
his campaign on appealing to low
information voters and in a very
emotional way these things are really
just not sticking and hopefully they'll
have a cumulative effect as we get into
the debates and closer to November but
individually no one incident seems to
have hurt him overwhelmingly although
certainly attacking that gold star dad
did not help by any means more be Parker
is offering a free five day home Tryon
to give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses I personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trialed comm
slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300
prescription glasses hi which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing